Wake the f**k off Americans?!
I'm here to talk some sense into you!
Well, hold on a second, I'm Canadian.
And when I say Americans,
I'm including Canadians in that, because...
Canadians, admit it,
we're really just the 51st state
We're like California with igloos.
So, Canadians, Americans... same thing
Anyway, what I was saying?
Wake the f**k off Americans?!
I'm here to talk some sense into you
As a nation, we suck with languages.
43% of all people around the world are bilingual.
That's includes over 50% of the people in Europe.
And in some countries like Indonesia and the Philippines,
virtually everybody is bilingual.
And it's very common that a lot of countries,
for people to speak 3, 4 or even 5 languages.
On a regular basis
But, in America, only 20% of the people are bilingual.
And guess what...
Almost all of those people are  immigrants
or the children of immigrants.
Amongst homegrown Americans, very few are bilingual.
And in the northern province of Canada,
the situation is not much different.
Most of the people who are bilingual,
are immigrants or Francophone Canadians,
french-speaking Canadians
Anglophone Canadians are generally monolingual.
Very few of them are bilingual.
In Australia, the numbers are even worse.
And in Europe, guess which country has
the lower level of bilingualism?
Hint:
The UK and Ireland!
So the point I'm making is that Anglophones
basically do NOT become bilingual.
I don't want to say Anglophones are lazy, but...
Why the hell are we so damn lazy?!
Well, obviously, it's because of a lack of incentive
English is the international language
So, why should I put in all this time
and effort to speak another language
when other people will just speak
english with me?
Isn't it kind of sort of arrogant to expect all the other
people to put in all the effort to accommodate us?
Anybody who has traveled have problably seen Americans or other Anglophones
getting frustrated with the locals
when they couldn't speak English.
But, if those Anglophones had ever learned
a second language for themselves,
maybe they would be able to understand
and empathize with that other person
and find the way to communicate with them
The truth is: English is NOT spoken
by most people in the world,
despite the fact that it's
the de facto international language
Most people simple don't speak English,
unless you stick to the main tourist traps.
And who likes cheesy tourist traps?
Knowing another major language can greatly
help you to communicate around the world
there's also no guarantee that English will be
the international language for much longer.
Not too long ago, the international language was French.
And in the future, maybe, it will be Chinese or Spanish.
Who knows?
Well, problably, won't be Chinese, but, you never know.
The number of Spanish-speakers is growing rapidly
and a lot of Spanish-speaking countries are
in the process of developing rapidly.
So, Spanish could become much
more important in the near future.
But, even if Spanish never becomes
the de facto international language,
there's no denying that knowing Spanish would be
incredibly useful in a lot of places around the world.
What do I care? I never leave my hometown.
But, even if there were no practical benefits
to learn a second language,
learning another language simply makes you smarter.
Do you want to be STUPID?
Learning a second language
actually makes you brain grow.
- It increases your memory.
- It increases your attention span.
- It helps you deal with ambiguities
and nuance In meanings
- It makes you more at multitasking
and adapting to new circumstances.
And learning a second language helps
offset the beginning of dementia.
By years up to five years in fact.
(Wow)
Learning a language is brain exercise.
Learning a language also helps to in less tangible ways
It helps you understand different ways of seeing reality.
Look at this color right here, what color this?
If you're an English speaker,
you probably thought that's blue.
Now, have a look at this color right here, ...
what color is that?
if you're an English-speaker, you might be thinking:
"Well, that's a shade of blue. That's light blue."
But, if you're Japanese,
then you probably thought this is a different color.
That's not blue, it's actually "watercolor".
in Japanese, these are two different colors.
People perceive them as different colors
because they have two different names for these colors.
But, wait that doesn't make sense,
they're just two shades of the same color.
I don't understand!
Oh really?
Okay, well how about this color right here?
Would you say that's red?
Okay.
How about this color right here?
if you're an English-speaker,
you probably said that's pink.
but, there are a lot of languages in the world
that do not see this as pink.
They see this as a shade of red.
The same way that you see light blue as a shade of blue.
(Weird)
These ways of perceiving reality
are the core of what we call culture.
By understanding different ways of perceiving reality,
we are understanding cultural variation,
cultural difference.
That greater cultural understanding can bring people
together, can create greater international relationships
and can maybe even prevent WARS!
How many wars have broken out because
the two sides couldn't comprehend each other way
of perceiving the situation?
I can only imagine.
So, Anglophones, stop being the laughingstock
of the world and stop selling yourself short.
Start learning a foreign language
and expand your mind.
(Hmmm...)
This is Paul.
Thank you for watching the LangFocus channel.
Leave your comments down below.
Talk to you later, have a good night.